eine opernsängerin sonst steht in der
semperoper hat nun vor einem altenheim
gesungen um dort den tag etwas zu
verschönern
für alle die sich fragen was das für ein
klang am elbufer in hamburg ist die
opernsängerin gala el hadidi singt
ungewohnter weise mit maske für die die
in den letzten tagen wenig menschlichen
kontakten erfahren durften
für die senioren ja das war auf jeden
fall eine premiere ja war ein bisschen
natürlich eine zumutung als sängerin
überhaupt mit eine maske zu singen aber
es war es war wirklich sehr sehr schön
hier
[Musik]
es ist sehr schwer über ein monat
tatsächlich keinen wirklichen menschen
menschlichen kontakt zu haben
nicht umarmt zu werden nicht
angesprochen zu werden
vielleicht haben sie auch gemerkt bei
gerade beim internet facebook und
instagram und so weiter gibt es auch
sehr viele so heim konzerte oder
wohnzimmer konzerte aber hier
diese altersgruppe ich glaube nicht dass
sie wirklich bei instagram oder bei
facebook überhaupt sind und aufgrund
dessen habe ich gesagt nee ich würde
gerne mal etwas kleines für den singen
und ja ich will den sagen sie sind nicht
alleine es gibt sehr viele menschen
draußen die an sie denken und denen
alles gute wünschen
die bewohner sind sehr dankbar denn sie
bekommen nicht viel besuch in dieser
schwierigen zeit sehr gut gefallen und
die stimmen von der sängerin die hat
mich wirklich zu tränen gerührt und dass
wir hierher kommen es uns besucht hat
[Musik]
also so wie man das gesehen hat es sind
sehr viele bewohner unten gewesen der
rest hat auf den zimmern zu gehört es
ist für alle schönen ereignis und eine
große abwechslung wenn so was
stattfindet war ja doch vieles
eingeschränkt ist und wir wirklich aus
der situation die jetzt ist das beste
machen müssen
[Musik]
[Applaus]